Ross and I are here with the Incredible
Dr Suzanne gilberg lens our resident
Health
Guru true expert she is here to help us
all live the healthiest and most
elongated life we can before we go let's
check in with Dr Jacob and Nick oh my
gosh we're so proud of you Dr Jacob how
did it go I feel fine I feel great it
went smooth it went great everything
went according to plan nothing funny
um and like we said before it's a fairly
simple procedure um you know we find it
we snip it we tie it burn it put it back
great and Nick we got to ask how do you
feel uh I feel pretty good I was I'm a
little embarrassed that I was so nervous
to be honest uh but Dr Jacob did an
amazing job good well you know it it
really is a first and it's uh it's
having a conversation that we haven't
really been having before I think it's
really Brave what you did today thank
you so much thank you Nick thank thank
you Dr Jacob thank you Dr
marel for letting us take a peek behind
the curtain for this incredibly
important procedure and always thank you
to Dr Suzanne gilberg lens for all of
your medical wisdom and KN how it's a
game Cher for us and honestly to be in
this in a partnership with you means
everything in the world to me
[Applause]
a love this
dog everybody we made this show for you
so just take it with you it's all
[Applause]
[Music]
yours